I Do not like the looks of this giant fight
chamber.
Bird person? it is now Phoenix person.
What did they do to you BP it is now PP.
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Rick and Morty season
four episode 10 finale video a whole bunch
of Easter eggs all talk a little bit about
what's going on with season five at the end
of the video to if you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the Easter
eggs will do a new Rick and Morty merge giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite episode from the season
on the video so careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the episode yet will
be top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go along.
Starting with number 10, the title of the
episode star Mort Rick turn of the Jerry a
Star Wars return of the Jedi reference and
in a rare moment, the title of the episode
was liberally reference throughout the episode
by Rick when he kept referring to all of the
other bets adventures is being a little too
much like Star Wars the by the final act even
full on saying out loud they were going to
do a Star Wars and referencing the death Star,
a couple times so number nine.
The opening scene welcome back in season three.
Beth at least we think that it season three.
Beth, we get the reveal of the Beth that thinks
that she's the real Beth from season three
episode nine making it seem like she really
did choose to clone herself and go on adventures
around the multi-verse later, we get a flashback
scene that clarifies what actually happened
in that she let Rick decide what to do.
The way the riders played the flashback twist
is a little more complicated all explained
why they did that, but now there is a full-blown
duplicate Beth which ever one you think is
the real one.
For the purposes of this video.
I'll call this one the hard-core.
Beth and this one that we been watching since
the season three finale regular Beth just
because she seems so regular hard-core.
Beth is revealed to be leading a resistance
group is fighting the new version of the Galactic Federation
This rebuilt itself from the ashes of their
defeat at the beginning of season three episode
one they'll specify exactly what planet they're on,
specifically the just on the capital city
of whatever this new Federation is in grovel
my territory, but sister making so many Star
Wars references will just call this their
version of course on you notice that hard-core.
Beth is running with a female squad.
She amongst her crew were still not quite
sure where Rick's friend squad.
She was after the season two finale.
After they all escape the wedding.
Speaking of which, I love that they brought
back that joke when Rick killed Tammy you
made me go to a wedding is also a robot here
that looks a little bit like the L3-37 droid
from solo a Star Wars story, but the whole
bit with her name being so lame that the crops
my guard has trouble remembering is just a
set up for the dueling best later and then
when hard-core.
Beth is at the Shoney's with Rick we never
let the Shoney's they also make fun of her
lame name again the number eight the death
Star or the new this star since the episode
is meant to be more of a return of the Jedi
Star Wars reference will call this version
of the second death Star and when the alien
is describing it in the clip.
He also makes a lot of jokes and references
about both of the dead stars saying they got
rid of all the design flaws there's no small
port where the rebels could blow it up the
bug design of the ship.
Kind of reminds me this old sci-fi series
called Lexx with a very phallic looking bug
shaped ship, but you just let me know what
kind of references you think they're making
with the design of this ship the joke about
the Wrangler jeans was just funny, but it
could actually be a genuine product integration
for the episode.
It's such a specific joke is reference so
many times throughout the episode planet killing
death Star brought to you by wranglers even
when they put the Wrangler jeans in the beam
to stop the death Star super laser maybe Levi
jeans gave them a ton of money or it could
just be them parroting bad product integration
and the over commercialization of the show.
Now that is become so popular Morty complains.
In some of their commercials to that they
do separately from the show about Rick always
selling them out for money why he keeps selling
us out.
Rick notice when hardcore.
Beth is watching this.
She's got a lot of prosthetics and cybernetic
body part replacements which is just 1 More
Way that she's evolved into the richest version
of Beth over here on the wall.
You can ask you see what seems like an upper
body torso replacement like a lot of her upper
body parts have been replaced with cybernetic
parts just like Rick, we get a really good
look at Rick's body parts when he's fighting
with Phoenix person later in the episode.
The fact that Rick stuck explosive devices
in both of the best next though is because
he wasn't sure which one was the clone suite
in the very Rick thing of making the cynical
choice assuming that they're both potential
threats which compounds his grief later when
he acknowledges what a terrible father.
He is number seven Dr. Wong from pickle Rick
is back.
They release the scene early last week and
I totally didn't think they go so far as to
get Susan Sarandon to come back to do new
voiceover for the episode because her scene
is really short.
They credited her as an official guest star
in the episode suite as they did get her to
come back, or they just use extra lines of
dialogue that they deleted from season three
episode three that they didn't wind up using
before.
Even if they did use old lines of dialogue
instead of actually bringing her back into
a booth to record new lines.
They still have to credit her as a guest star
during the episode.
Either way, it was still pretty big surprise.
They brought her back at all.
But the whole premise of her coming back is
just a reference the pickle Rick therapy episode
again even reference that episode earlier
in another episode when Rick makes fun of
Morty for his bad ideas.
If you felt like you heard them reference
the pickle Rick episode a lot this season
is because they want to couple enemies for
it so it's there most critically lauded episode
such as them, patting themselves in the back
like look at how awesome this one episode
during season three was even though if you
ask people what their favorite episode of
season three was they give you a bunch of
different answers.
They also use this intro scene to set up Morty
and Summers invisibility belt arc that leads
them to team up like Luke and Leah later in
the episode, which they directly reference
when they're on the death Star more Star Wars
references except summer says no brother sister
kissing this time and apparently Hansel and
Gretel were totally doing with each other
even though they make fun of their own storyline
breaking the fourth wall later in the episode.
They do get some fun out of the invisibility
belt with both Morty and summer being as deluded
as possible, which is very on brand for both
of them summer use that to stalk her crush
in his bedroom she seems like she is DTF watch
out she is a freak Morty as expected tries
use it to people in the cheerleaders and practice
anime tries to get in the shower before summer
comes to get them but notice the clock in
her crutches room here is on military time.
It seems a little weird.
They would do it that way, but some people
do use military time Morty's old belt being
tiny big man Junior just seems like it's a
regular belt and that's the name of the brand.
It doesn't seem like it has any special functions
more even directly calls out the TV show to
catch a predator and when this guy catches
summer in his room.
Look at the picture on his wall.
This family is just absolutely creep tastic.
Number six Beth versus Rick so this is a good
stand out because it shows you how this version
of Beth is trying to out Rick Rick with her
gadgets and attacks wanted to feel like he's
met his match like if anybody in the multi-verse
would be capable of taking him on it will
be another top-tier version of Rick or a top-tier
version of Beth which this Beth has evolved
into.
I feel like the horse head on her jacket is
also a bit of a call back to her love of ponies
is a little girl like she's living out her
best life all the things that she always wanted
to do for herself.
They both throw red and blue pokemon balls
at each other that release monsters tearing
each other apart the look very much like Pokemon
ripoffs this blue and even kind of has a Pikachu
tail you can let me know which other Pok\'e9mon
you think they resembled most but I think
they're just meant to be copyright save them
all comes of a bunch of different Pok\'e9mon
so that the Rick and Morty people don't get
sued by Nintendo for ripping off Pok\'e9mon
Rick tries to play both best during the episode
as to who's the real one and who's the clone,
but in reality he doesn't know either because
he was playing to card Monte shuffling the
tanks that he would know the difference.
They also give you a sense for how the two
beds diverged when hard-core.
Beth is disgusted at herself at the thought
that she went back to Jerry in the season
three finale.
That's another call back to her being just
like Rick because who does Rick hate the most.
Rick hates himself the most and now Beth hates
herself literally the most.
So number five.
The Federation invades earth again and Rick
kills Tammy they took over at the end of the
season two finale.
But then left in season three episode one.
After Rick crushed the government but best
poster here seems like the writing is supposed
to be a reference to our abashed which is
the written language in all the Star Wars
movies and TV shows.
They set the bit about Rick not being a threat
to the government anymore when he tells Beth
his philosophy on Galactic coups.
The trick is to be left alone by whoever takes
over which Tammy then calls out, when she
says they're neutralizing him effectively
by leaving him alone.
You will be a threat as long as we leave you
alone.
Rick references his hero face.
That's the period in his life.
The bird person was talking to Morty about
when Beth believed that he'd abandon her as
a child when she was growing up later when
both of the beds are yelling at each other.
They reference a 30-year-old version of Rick
saying that hard-core.
Beth is trying to be like that 30-year-old
version of Rick who was in his hero phase
inside Dr. Wong's therapy session.
She drags Jerry for the sock puppet and references
the great British bake-off TV show Tammy returns
for real this time.
Not like the fake story train version of Tammy.
I love that Jerry also keeps getting her name
wrong Tonya Tammy what was your name again.
I love that he calls her Tammy like that's
an actual name, Rick keeps making fun of Dr.
Wong again, because he's always hated therapy
all more callbacks to the pickle Rick episode.
We also learn he planted tech all over the
office just like the home to activate when
he said certain phrases out loud just so that
he could bail on therapy one of them being
an incinerator that was supposed to destroy
Dr. Wong herself, because it incinerated her
chair when she would normally be sitting but
he catches Tammy in the fire scarring her
face, which is because were going for Star
Wars Easter eggs Anakin Skywalker, Darth Vader
reference make all the Rick Sanchez high ground
references you want when she says I'm better
than this job that's also 1/4 wall break from
Susan Sarandon just a meta-joke about her
in real life being better than this acting
job doing a voiceover character on Rick and
Morty like I'm too famous for this you notice
that hard-core Beth spaceship is designed
to look a little bit like Anakin Skywalker's
starfighter from revenge of the Sith those
are called exit to act as class interceptors
they reference a whole bunch of fast food
brands in a really short time span.
So some or all of these might be actual product
integrations to earn more money for the show
because Rick mentions McDonald's as if it's
like a big treat.
He loves it.
Then Wendy's he loves that even more than
they directly reference their Wendy's commercial
they been airing all season saying I love
Wendy's.
I think they even gave us some money.
This end of the fourth wall break because
the Wendy's Corporation literally gave them
a dump truck of money to do that commercial
and it's another integration within this episode
if you understand how TV is monetized and
made with integrations.
They are really cashing in on this episode.
They also give another Wrangler jeans shout
out Morty in summer break the fourth wall
when they're talking about their story arc
during the episode.
Hey, it's not Citizen Kane, but why compete
with whatever's going on here, which is the
riders just making fun of themselves.
Acknowledging that the Morty summer arc in
the episode isn't nearly as interesting is
what's going on with the two versions of Beth
in the Federation.
Rick kills Tammy joking about the wedding.
You may be go to a wedding, then obviously
tries to take it back because technically
killing his best friend bird person should
be way worse than making him go to a wedding
remember Rick didn't know about the Phoenix
person twist to the end of this episode in
the big reveal we've known about it since
season three episode one the number four they
go do a Star Wars Rick directly calls out Star Wars
saying they have to go do a Star Wars and
head to the death Star is really quick portal
trick with a small squadron of ships is also
a good indicator for how much he holds back
and fights he's way more powerful and smarter
than he lets on.
So most of the time when it seems like he
loses, especially when he is with the rest
of the family like they one of him.
Usually that's him letting them win because
he really does love his family despite how
much she complains about it later in the episode.
They sort of bring that back around when they're
the ones to save him from Phoenix person Rick
breaks the fourth wall again when he says
Tammy was over serialized meaning that the
writers think that they use the character
too many times and too many episodes and he
reminds Morty in summer not to kill themselves
trying to save this earth because there are
infinite earth that they can escape to Kronenberg
and squirrels style.
If they need to pack it up, the number three
Rick versus Phoenix person.
When he references the giant fight chamber.
That's a reference to the Emperor's throne
room from the second a star and return of
the Jedi, because the whole fight scene is
meant to be a big reference to the Luke Skywalker
versus Darth Vader fight scene return of the
Jedi they reference their history together
several times Phoenix person has him dead
to rights like I said, but then it's Rick's
family that saves them the actual fight scene
itself was animated great.
I love how anime they get with this fight
scene is also very reminiscent of the fight
that Rick had with the president and season
three episode 10 with them both kinda being
bad ass is one upping each other along the
way Morty in summer disable the death Star
super laser with his jeans bringing the Wrangler
jokes around Full Circle, Morty going pants-less
for most of the rest of the episodes flapping
around in the wind, the number two the ending
scene of the episode where they reassert Rick's
lowered status in the family sort of returning
the family dynamic to what it normally is.
Although we have the addition of the extra
Beth now, everyone kinda thinks of them is
a bad dad at Morty in summer totally cool
with the alternate version of Beth because
she's way cooler than the original best we
know they have two badass moms the memory
bile is a big call back to Morty's mind blowers.
I don't know what the going to be doing going
forward with this alternate version of Beth
but they connection develop a spinoff series
with her with her going off on her other adventures
because there's another joke about another
franchise spinoff series in a post credit
scene that all talk about the second to but
it sounds like going forward this new alternate
Beth is cannon so she will continue to show
up every once in a while in the show.
Who knows when, shall come back again.
Maybe those bring her back in season five,
episode one, or maybe shall come back a couple
more times the new original song that they
did for this whole montage was Ashley pretty
solid in notice in the background of this
flashback video in the tank behind the clone
tanks there's this tiny baby Cthulhu in a
jar that's implied to be the one from the
intro scene that we been seeing ever since
the beginning of the series that it's also
revealed that even though Rick is a terrible
dad as he says he is a pretty good friend
and he rescued Phoenix person in a bid to
try and save him and is keeping him in the
garage behind this shelf wall with the box
of time travel stuff, so that's cannon now
until you see Rick release him or fully heal
him.
He's always going to be chilling out behind
this wall in all the season five episodes.
Would it be funny if because this is such
a big twist is they just released him and
season five, episode one like right Phoenix
person you're back to normal here done take
off now in number one WTF the post credit
scene with a joke about Jerry's spinoff series
about the invisible garbage truck.
Dan Harmon did a lot of these improvise funny
songs for his Harmon town podcast we would
just make them up on the fly the Joker the
spinoff series, though, is that it only lasts
until Jerry runs out of gas because he can't
find the invisible gas tank to refill the truck.
It was fun while it lasted.
We had a good run and he metaphorically got
to take out the trash when he took out the
pimp the other Easter egg here right at the
end is for this man and the dog here.
This is meant to be Mike Mendel.
He was the Rick and Morty producer that passed
away at the beginning of the season.
They just added him to the scene here just
to memorialize him again.
They did a special post credit scene for him
at the end of season for episode one as well.
But what will happen is is all do a season
five teaser and predictions video tomorrow
talking about what's going on with the season
five episodes.
So as long as you have alerts able for my
channel.
You should see that video when I posted but
everyone just let me know in the comments
if he spotted any big Easter eggs in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video I feel
it was probably one of the best episodes of
the season if not the best is the way they
brought things back around most of the time.
I tend to like the canonical heavy serialized
episodes more than the one offs, but sometimes
some of their one offs are pretty solid so
everyone click here for all my Rick and Morty
episodes and click here for that brand-new
Marvel internals teaser.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe see you guys tonight!